بالنسبه للاولويات كان علينا استعاده
الثقه وخصوصا في مناطق الازمات من دون
الحد الادنى من الثقه لا يمكننا ان نتقدم
وان نعالج الازمات هذه كانت مساله مهمه
بالنسبه لي وهذا ما حاولت ان افعله اي
تفاهم الناس مع بعضهم وان يبدي كل طرف
رايه بصراحه او بين المسائل التاريخيه في
كل بلد كانت هذه في طليعه اولويات الامر
الثاني الذي كان يهمني هو اسمه صوت فرنسا
المستلم من القيم الديجوليه وان يتم تاكيد
ذلك من قبل السفراء الاكثر كفايه ان
السياسه الخارجيه في فرنسا لا يقررها وزير
الخارجيه ان سياسه الدوله يقررها رئيس
الجمهوريه وزير الخارجيه ياتي لتطبيق هذه
السياسه
لتنفيذ هذه السياسه الشخصيه الطباعه
للوزير تؤثر وهنا تحدث عن برناركوشنير على
سبيل المثال جورج مال برونو كتب في
لوفيجارو يقول ان العالم العربي مثلا كان
سعيدا بقلب صفحه برناركوشنر منوه بك شخصيا
كوزيره خارجيه تعرفين العالم العربي عن
كثب لماذا باعتقادك وهل فعلا كان العالم
سعيدا بقلب صفحه برنار
كان سعيدا بالحد الادنى لانني كنت اعرف
العالم العربي وكان المسؤولون يعرفونني
منذ كنت وزيره لدفاع كان لديه الكثير من
الاتصالات ولا سينما في فتره حرب الخليج
حيث كان لفرنسا موقفا قوي
ارسلني مرات عدى للحديث مع قاده العالم
العربي ونحن كنا نعرف بعضنا واعتقد اننا
نجحنا في بناء علاقه ثقه شخصيه الشيخ محمد
بن زايد قال لي مره عندما تتكلمين نعرف ان
هناك شيئا ملموس سيحصل على المستوى
الدفاعيه تم توقيعه عدد من الاتفاقات وهذا
اكد ان زيارات لم تكن مجرد سفره عابره
اتكلم فيها بعض العبارات الجميله ثم اذهب
كنت عندما اقول شيئا يتم تنفيذ ما اقوله
لهذا كان البعض مسرورا عندما تسلمت
الوزاره ربما لانني ديغوليه على ما اعتقد
ولاننا حافظنا على التقليد الديكولي في
العلاقات بين فرنسا والعالم العربي وهذا
كان له اثاره في رد الفعل احيالي بطبيعه
الحال